salut aujourd'hui dans libé un article
sur les youtuber et sur le youtube km en
général et j'ai été cité à l'intérieur
et en ce moment tous les youtuber tous
les créateurs parle du changement
d'algorithme a enfin l'aldouane qui est
toujours modifier de manière en
permanence des pertes d'abonnés ça aussi
je le subis etc
mais c'est pas de ça que je vais vous
parler aujourd'hui aujourd'hui j'ai
répondu à une question que j'ai beaucoup
reçu sur facebook et par mail et sur
instagram aussi c'était une petite
récurrence de l'année je n'ai jamais
traité comme on arrive en fin de l'année
je me dis je vais le faire au moins une
fois voici mes cinq conseils si jamais
vous voulez vous lancer sur youtube en
2017 generis ans je sais pas si je suis
le meilleur placée pour donner des
conseils en tout cas ce sont les miens
et ne correspondent donc peut-être vous
trouverez des choses inspirante à
l'intérieur le premier conseil que je
pourrais vous donner c'est de vous
donner des objectifs mais attention
qu'on dit objectif c'est pas un objectif
de nombre d'abonnés avant telle date
c'est pas non plus un objectif de vues
quotidiennes pour la simple et bonne
raison que ce sont des objectifs sur
lesquels vous pouvez pas influé
directement
donnez vous des objectifs qui vous
concerne vous directement dans l'exemple
de ce que j'ai fait cette année mon
objectif était de faire une vidéo par
jour pendant un an du 1er janvier au 31
décembre
peu importe le nombre d'abonnés peu
importe le nombre de vues qui a été fait
au cours de l'année je gardais ce défi
et je remplissais mon objectif à moi
donc quoi qu'il arrive je ne peux être
que satisfait lorsque j'ai rempli
l'objectif dans le sens où il ne tient
qu'à moi de le faire ou pas vous
comprenez ce que je veux dire c'est pas
vous qui allez décider que les gens vont
vous suivre ou pas c'est pas vous qui
allez décider que les gens regardent ou
pas mais vous pouvez avoir des objectifs
sur ce que vous vous faites par exemple
la périodicité par exemple la manière de
filmer par exemple un certain type de
contenu les objectifs c'est toujours
stimulant deuxième conseil trouver qui
vous êtes
au-delà du contenu de ce que vous avez
produire trouver qui vous êtes et ce qui
vous passionne réellement j'aurais pu
parler par exemple de gaming parce que
j'aime bien jouer aux jeux vidéo mais je
me connais pas tellement on va pas dire
que je suis un passionné des jeux vidéo
pas un truc que je suis en permanence et
pas un truc que je fais en permanence ça
ne m'aurait pas correspondu vous devez
savoir profondément qui vous êtes comme
ça peu importe le contenu que vous
produisez il est sincère et vous devez
faire vous parler de ce que vous aimez
faire ou de ce que vous aimez parler ça
veut pas dire de ne pas travailler faire
un texte une mise en scène tout ce que
vous voulez mais ça doit partir de vous
ça doit vous ressemblez sinon vous
n'avez pas le tenir dans le temps en
troisième conseil qui serait sûrement
d'ailleurs mon meilleur conseil à l'est
vous formez sur le créateur academy dans
la créateur à l'académie sur youtube
vous tapez youtube creator academy vous
avez trouvé ça très facilement il ya
énormément de courses est très bien fait
c'est exactement ce qu'on retrouve dans
les youtube space qu'on va faire les
workshops c'est hyper précis et c'est
assez drôle parce que ça a pas l'air
tellement utilisé moi je me suis formé à
fond avec ça et ça répond à toutes les
questions en termes de stratégie en
terme de stratégie de contenu en terme
de production comment produire en termes
de réseau en termes de communication il
ya tout dans la créateur academy allez-y
foncez il ya plein de courses est
parfait quatrième conseil pensez à faire
des choses viable la viabilité c'est à
dire est ce que dans le temps c'est
viable je prendre un contre exemple
imaginer que pour vos premières vidéos
vous mobilisiez beaucoup de personnes
vous mettiez peut-être un peu dessous
même sur le tournage que ce soit quelque
chose de très longs à faire très long à
produire lorsque vous allez mettre la
vidéo en ligne
si elle a pas beaucoup de vue vous allez
être complètement démotivés parce que
pour faire la prochaine faut remettre
tout ça en place c'était compliqué dans
un premier temps fait un contenu viable
c'est-à-dire pas extrêmement
contraignant à produire vous aurez déjà
énormément de contraintes entre le
montage l'habillage la mise en ligne
découvrir tout ce qui est à découvrir
répondre au commentaire si jamais vous
êtes quelqu'un de plutôt proche des gens
qui vous regardent crois vraiment que
quand on commence il faut il faut
simplifier la tâche au maximum moi c'est
ce que j'ai fait je fais tout avec
l'alegria j'ai juste une lumière chez
mon montage sur final cut
pourtant c'est déjà extrêmement long et
compliqué si j'avais eu un set up plus
complexe que je n'aurais pas eu etc
j'aurais lâché le défi en cours de route
donc fait des choses viable
n'investissez pas plus que vous ne
pouvez investir après dans le long terme
fait des choses que vous pouvez
reproduire d'une manière aisée sap à
dire facile mais c'est à dire vous savez
que vous êtes capable de le reproduire
régulièrement sans problème et enfin de
mon dernier conseil c'est penser à la
partage habilité je pense si ce mot
existe et à l'actualité
alors c'est pas quelque chose que je
fais beaucoup moi pour le coup mais ça
marche plutôt bien en termes de les
vidéos qui marche de se fier à
l'actualité de faire en fonction des
tendances un film qui sort une actualité
récente d'être dans l'air du temps là
c'est noël en ce moment il ya pas mal de
youtube heures qui font des calendriers
de l'avent qui sans rapport direct avec
noël essayer d'être dans l'air du temps
et là c'est ce qu'on entend derrière
partager bilité ça veut dire que est ce
que si quelqu'un regarde la vidéo est ce
qu'il a envie de la partager
en général on partage les vidéos on
apprend quelque chose où on a vu quelque
chose un peu what the fuck
vous pouvez prendre ces deux contraintes
en tête je vous le dis c'est pas quelque
chose moi que j'ai fait mais force est
de constater que ça fonctionne très bien
et même des personnes qui tiennent des
calendriers dans des fichiers où ils ont
marqué la sortie de tous les
blockbusters de l'année
les événements qui aura 2 marquant dans
l'année certains événements sportifs de
l'année comme ça ils savent quand ils
écrivent que telle vidéo du mois de juin
va plus parler de sites est celle du
mois de juillet de cela et c'est assez
couteau intéressant voilà pour les
scènes conseil si vous voulez vous
lancer sur youtube en 2017 mais faites
le en fait fait les vidéos vous a envie
de faire peut-être vous en ferai une
peut-être vous en ferez sans peut-être
n'arrêterai jamais peut-être vous
arrêterez très vite mais ne vous privez
pas de l' envie de le faire juste ne
focalisez pas sur les vues sur les
abonnés ça paraît facile à dire comme ça
mais tous ceux qui ont fait des vidéos
sont passés par peu de vue et peu
d'abonnés donc ça empêche pas d'avoir
envie de faire les vidéos faites les
d'abord pour voir vos propres objectifs
mais n'hésitez pas à le faire vous
n'avez pas à pas grand-chose à perdre en
fait si une vidéo ne vous plait plus
vous l'assumez pubins voulait face ray
c'est pas très grave
et si vous avez déjà une chaîne et que
vous même vous avez un conseil vous
semblez ultra pertinent ajouté n'hésitez
pas à le mettre dans les commentaires ce
sera très bien pour les personnes qui
veulent en faire ou celle qui en font
déjà de lire un peu l'expérience des
autres comme moi je voulais partager la
mienne aujourd'hui si la vidéo vous a
plu comme tous les jours vous pouvez la
laque et où vous abonner rendez vous
demain à 17h ciao
là haut
[Musique]